[Music]
so let's start with anger because you
know in between my rainmaking activities
in the dry alpine
west i also make time for stupid
arguments over breakfast one of which i
had this morning i think that was also
precipitated by yours truly so not all
great things
and
you mentioned you have a number of
stories before we started recording
related to anger so let's let's start
there and i'll i'll let you lead
wherever you think it makes sense
i will but let me ask you a question
first
why do you ask about anchor what is your
intention or what makes you ask well i
ask about anger because
i notice
as i reflect on
not just my own behavior but behavior
that is common in my family
a tendency towards perhaps an emotional
home base of anger it's a very familiar
feeling
and i recognize how it can be corrosive
and i've spoken to people who have
wanted to discuss their respective
perspectives on say clean anger
i have tried to contend with it
in different ways some have suggested
fully expressing it
hitting a pillow working on a punching
bag that tends to amplify and
perpetuate anger in me so it does not
have the desired effect of dissipating
anger at all it just
turns it from a seven to a ten
and
it's something i want to work on because
i also recognize that even when i convey
neutral content from the perspective of
the words that i choose sometimes my
tone has an undercurrent of anger
and that causes strife that causes
arguments that causes
various types of tension and
a lot of it most of it is not helpful so
that is that is part of why i ask and
if if i may just add one more thing from
a
macro societal perspective i have never
seen more polarization and anger
than i see today just observing this
audience of let's call it 10 to 20
million people a month
as i look at all of it from a 30 000
foot view i have never seen
so much
anger and hostility ever
in all my time on this planet so that's
also frightening
so that really helps me a lot because
your openness about it is actually what
we need if we bury it or stuff it
it just festers and as you say you can
try to be nice and it seeps out in the
tone of your voice and people feel that
we we resonate with one another it's not
a complicated thing you could call it
mystical but if you put a violin on the
table and somebody else plays a violin
nearby the strings of both of them will
resonate and so
yes there you're looking so nice and
then that little
stuff seeps out so i've i've really had
to wrestle with anger a lot
and the greeks call it a noble emotion
the philosophers because there's
something of value in it so the first
thing i want to say is that anger in
itself isn't bad it's difficult to work
with but it's not a bad thing
it's something for us to understand
because it's part of human incarnation
and often the anger
comes out of hurt
or it comes out of fear
ways that we feel vulnerable it's a way
of protecting ourselves
james baldwin said i believe the reason
that people cling to their hate and
anger so stubbornly
is because
they're afraid that once hate is gone
they'll be forced to face their own pain
and so we also project it on others you
know the ones that that cause our pain
and so forth instead we get angry
as if they were the ones making it
happen and we have the enemy du jour it
doesn't matter right now it's russian
everybody's cheering we have a the
pentagon is like
you know
i don't know what to say they're they're
celebrating we have a great enemy again
and a bigger budget and so forth you
know but it can be the immigrants or the
mexicans or the blacks or the gays or
the you know whoever it is the enemy du
jour
because we can't bear our insecurity
and we can't bear the fact that we're
vulnerable in certain ways
and that what's out there is also part
of us so alexander solzhenitsyn the
great russian author when he was in the
gulags writing these brilliant things
and sent out the
siberia he said if only it were simple
if only we could just round up the evil
people and get rid of them
but the problem is the line dividing
good and evil
cuts through
the heart of every human being
and who among us is willing to get
to to get rid of a piece of our own
heart
so this is where we are as human beings
so here i am
i'm in the monastery i did some years
training as a buddhist monk
and in my family there were four boys
and we each had different roles my
brother got angry a lot i think that was
the healthiest in some way because my
father was
angry paranoid wife batterer
somewhat mentally ill and also a
brilliant scientist who helped develop
some of the first artificial hearts and
lungs and did space medicine and stuff
but he was she was a terrifying figure
in many ways
so i was the peacemaker in the family
trying to calm it down
i've now made that a profession you know
how that goes
and i go in the monastery and i'm
sitting minding my own business
meditating walking slowly in the forest
in the remote part of thailand on the
border of laos that's
an ascetic forest monastery i wanted
something tough you know we're a young
man is there anything dangerous to do
around here let me try it
and i start to sit
and at some point not not that long in
my time there the first months i start
to get more and more irritated at the
way the monks around me are behaving and
the problems and you know this one and
that one and then i just noticed that
i'm getting angrier
and all of a sudden i realize
that i have a lot of anger
it just starts boiling up because
there's no distraction and i can't put
it on somebody else really
and and so i go to talk to my teacher
about it i said you know all this anger
is bubbling up and basically it shocked
me because i thought i was a peaceful
person and mostly i just didn't want to
be like my father and hurt people
so i'm not going to be like him but it
turns out
he's in there and it's all in there
and and i tell him my teacher
and he looks at me and he says good
he said great this this is what you need
to look at
he said i want you to go back to your
little hut and a tin roof
you know close the one window and door
put on all your robes this is the hot
season and if you're going to be angry
do it right he didn't say go beat
something he just said sit in the middle
of it take the seat
and feel the fire of it and learn first
of all learn to tolerate it
because part of what happens with anger
is when we can't tolerate the emotions
and so forth then we lash out or it
leaks in our words
we said so go and sit and bring your
mindfulness to it and learn
to tolerate it because a lot of the
power of meditation as the
neuroscientists say
is to increase the window of tolerance
so you don't get reactive to things but
you have the ability to feel things
fully and then decide how to express it
so i sit there
and after a while it's like okay anger
comes and the great image in in the
buddhist teaching is that the buddha
seated under the
tree of enlightenment that big world
story or myth and while he's sitting
there he gets attacked by the armies of
mara you have no right to sit here mara
comes as doubt
mara brings temptations you know and
then it was all the beautiful maidens
and a golden chariot you could have all
these things that buddha says no been
there done that you know i want
something freer than that
and then mara attacks him with spears
and flaming arrows and things
and the buddha's response
is to say i see you mara
mark comes back other times in buddha's
life and the main thing that the buddha
does he doesn't fight mara doesn't con
says i see who you are i see you and in
that you can feel that there's a freedom
in the heart a spaciousness to be
present for it
so i get better with this [ __ ] right i'm
okay now i'm not not quite so angry i
know i have it
i leave the monastery after some years i
go back
to new england where i'd been last
hook up with an old girlfriend who was
great she was
doing graduate teaching at harvard
and very quickly we get into conflict
and i realized okay it's one thing to
deal with anger in myself
but being a monk
i had no training in how to deal with
relationship
you know and going back was hard
people talk about leaving the monastery
going back to their family they they
forget that both jesus and buddha had a
hard time when they went home to their
family
this is like the real place
so i'm there with this woman and all my
neurosis comes up my neediness my
whatever you know fears all the things
about around intimacy that i didn't have
to deal with as a monk so i start
to
do that and and i realized that anger is
building up again she was great actually
she said okay you dealt with it in
yourself
now let's let's do this together so she
says come with me she had an old volvo
station wagon and in the back she had 10
cases
big cases of bottles and she said come
with me she drove me to an old
place where they were demolishing a
brick building she said all right get
out i want you
throw those suckers at the wall you know
and say whatever you have so you just
about me but i've just let it out not so
much as pounding the bag but just making
it all conscious it wasn't like i have
to do that every day
and then i went into a reiki in therapy
and this guy said you have the monk
defense you can be aware of anything but
you're afraid to actually express it
so he said jack may i interrupt for a
second what type of therapist was that
he worked with wilhelm reich who was a
a contemporary right after freud who
worked with the energy and sexuality the
body and he asked me
what time of day is hardest for you
and i said morning i'm not a morning
person he said great i'll see you at 6
a.m
when your defenses are down
so i go in and he asks me to do these
breathing exercises to charge up my body
play some evocative music and starts
working on my body saying you've got to
let this stuff out whatever it is okay
he worked on my body so hard one day he
cracked two ribs actually
i wept i i cried i got angry i did all
these things so this was part of
my learning it
and now i'm a lot less afraid of it and
and therefore i also can use it so when
i had my house being rebuilt we were
supposed to go to europe and contractor
who was a good guy kept saying we're you
know we're a little behind i said we
you've got to finish before we travel
for a long time
he's putting it off and i kept asking
nice guy that i am and he says
finally i said
you know we've only got a month to go
and you little teams and i yelled at him
i said
man if you don't finish this i'm gonna
sue your ass in court i'm gonna get that
you know i'm just tired of this [ __ ] and
i'm really angry and he looks at me and
says oh you really want it done don't
you
and i said yeah next day he said like a
triple crew and i realized that i simply
needed to speak contractors i was kind
of speaking like buddhist monk but that
was not his language
so it became easier in some way
to work with it and to realize that you
know i have my own inner taliban i have
my own inner iron curtain that it's not
just out there
and by taking this energy and saying yes
this is something that i can work with
it just becomes much easier for me and
it runs through me quicker it's not that
it doesn't i mean i watch tick not han
or the dalai lama get angry or upset so
it's not like it won't it's part of us
and then i guess the last thing to say
because it also allows for a kind of
graciousness
about it
when i see myself getting angry
if you really look
what i really look underneath anger is
hurt or fear
or some kind of humiliation or something
like that where you feel like you've
been disrespected
and if i can drop from the anger to say
what what's under this
and then express it and say i really
feel hurt when you say that or that
makes me afraid
that very conflict
with another person or a group of people
it changes from being i'm right and
you're wrong to
this hurts or i'm afraid about this and
we can have a genuine conversation
that's entirely different
you